Lucas Lucas right so as we said before
there's this idea that these shapes
we've been talking about right circles
straight lines revelers we are used to
thinking of these as shapes that are
connected to some kind of equation right
and we are going to get to that idea but
before you get that idea idea of a
Bacchus ears here's my definition it's a
rule that defines or you should say a
geometric form I suppose because
remember when I gave you all these
instructions I was always saying you
know be this distance from that or from
these things or equal distance they're
all geometric terms it's a geometric
rule that defines a set of points okay
but you also remember I said you don't
have to just say well as an alternative
to saying a set of points they're all
just fixed in place you may also say
rather than a set of points and for a
point a single point that moves
okay so for instance let's go back to
the very first one I said this song
standing in the middle that's all gather
around right and have everyone standing
the same distance from them okay and
that's the set of points idea but I
could have said let's make it a point
that moves right by picturing say you
know you've got a stick in the middle
stuck in the ground okay and then you've
got like a I don't know a sheep or a cow
or something and you tie a rope around
its neck and then you tie the other end
to the stick and you say okay here's the
stick and here's your arm is your sheep
greatest illustration of all time okay
and because it's tied there right how is
it going to move well in exactly sorry
that's a terrible circle but you get the
idea okay so it's a single point that's
moving again according to this geometric
rule okay does that make sense okay so
and what do questions look like in this
topic right well it'll look like this
what you start with is this geometric
rule is which is inwards okay
in words okay
and typically the questions will say
alright don't you take that rule and can
you translate that for me okay what
would it mean if I had the same
geometric but instead of using natural
language can you use an equation alright
that's that's generally what this topic
is about occasionally you'll be asked to
go the other way right now say like that
they'll give you some kind of equation
or say now tell me can you describe what
this is like okay
can you describe the lockets that's
actually the language that they're used
in the question okay yeah yeah basically
okay in in a sense right the locus is
this part the geometric rule and you can
have it in either form okay but when
they say find the locus they really
should say find the equation of the
lockers
that's what properly written questions
will say and this is what they need
okay from here to here okay all right so
I start with a simple example the one
that we did at the beginning but let's
put it in sort of coordinate geometry
terms okay so Devon won a point this is
often how it starts
you can see if look at this second idea
there's a point and it's sort of moving
around doing around following a certain
right now because it's moving okay you
can't say the point is 3 4 or 1 1 or
negative 5 10 okay because if it were
then it would be stuck there it's static
it can't move around so in order to have
it moving we say it's X comma Y okay so
it's x and y con it's our variable they
can change right so that's why
okay so for point P and its corner two x
and y moves such that now when you see
those words such that what's about to
follow it is the geometric rule they're
about to tell you the behavior that this
thing has to exhibit such that it is
always let's see one minute away from
the point okay so there's the set up and
the actual question we do find the
equation of its lightest
okay now depending on how well you're
tracking with me and how the cogs in
your head are turning this question is
quite simple I've deliberately start off
with a simple example and you could
probably just just write down the answer
okay you could just actually say it to
me because I'm you're very familiar with
this kind of shape
right but sometimes the geometric rule
they give you will be weirdly confusing
they will be like the distance from here
is twice the distance from here which is
the angle for a while okay
so you can't just write it down you've
got to show some working so let's show
how it will actually pan out for a
question like this okay so I'm going to
say here's my working out I always begin
like in most questions right you want to
pick out the most important pieces of
information okay so you'd say oh there's
P which is an X Y then there's the other
point which is one two okay and then
they tell you that the distance between
these two distance ap right should
always be equal to one okay now in this
question because it's quite simple
that's that's all there is there are no
other facts that we need and we can work
this out there okay I'm going to start
from here okay this you can see I've
taken words and I've already written
down an equation this is the beginning
of our geometric rule in equation okay
so I've made the first step distance AP
go all the way back to you rate okay
that's when you learn the distance
equation between two points right so
rather than just saying you know words
I'm trying to go towards equations right
what is the distance formula does any
remember I just give me the general form
but in this case what does it start with
yeah yeah
good well done now question I always had
trouble with this okay so I wonder if
you have as well
I always got confused between which ones
were negatives negatives here and
positives how do you remember which ones
which this this equation right this
formula it comes from Pythagoras right
on the immediate previous line is this
the sum or sorry the square of the
hypotenuse is equal to the sum of the
squares of the shorter two sides okay so
when you look at this you'll all that
has to be plus no one gets confused
about Pythagoras right so if you ever
think about which way is it I'm just
going to mess up all your numbers
occasionally you'll get a negative under
the square root
that's one sign that's wrong but
secondly just think of where it came
from
okay all right let's move forward I'm
going to substitute that in here but
here are my actual specific details
here's my x1 y1 and here's my eggs to
the white okay now I get to confused the
X 1 is X okay and the y1 is why okay
they're not actual numbers I don't know
what they are because they can move
around and they can change okay so my
next line will be the square root of
what we got here
by X minus 1 all squared and then I've
got Y minus 2 or sweat that's each
now in a sense I've sort of that's
that's the hard part
I've got my distance this is an equation
right but I can probably make it a
little better right because the distance
formula is always positive right but
this means I could only be on one side
or in the positive side I can actually
go on either side as you guys did it
wrong we were costing around a bit right
so I can actually square both sides and
that's where we get the familiar
equation of a circle it's one squared
but it's just one yeah tah-dah
okay so I'm a fish right it was a pretty
simple question yeah okay you mean wait
hold on do you mean to say that like to
write down this instead yeah yeah okay I
would say in theory right I think you
demonstrate the same understanding
should be fine right however I prefer
this way of writing and doing an extra
set because what this does is it ties it
back to what the question actually said
which was about this part here this is
the distance always one unit away okay
so for that reason I'm gonna I'm going
to go and go ahead and do that and later
on sometimes it'll be important you have
to no choice okay all right so that was
pretty simple example what was the
second one we said there were two points
and I wanted you all to be equidistant
from those points okay so you help me
let's get rid of [ __ ] sorry don't worry
there will be plenty more sheep this
year I like drawing sheet um because
they're easy to control anyway I once
tried to draw horses and I'm like this
is a bad idea like that
Nichkhun all right so I'm gonna have two
points what should we call them my
pretty boring mathematicians okay sure I
was I was gonna say B but that's fine
all right um give me some coordinates
what's the first one not not Jesse he's
going to give me something we please
save me from Jesse's we coordinate
wha-ha-ha okay we get coupons boring
coordinates okay and something else
- my - Vlad six okay
there's done all right now by the way
sorry I actually forgot a crucial step
we didn't I didn't ask you to but
usually it's a good idea to often
they'll say find the equation and in
drawing right so really quickly what is
this look like you've got one - okay
there's my Center and everything is one
unit so I'm going to go this far this
far this far it's known as the parent
circle but it'll do me okay so I'll oh I
just wanted to put beyond the center
there and there's an intercept finished
um no you don't usually if they want you
to they'll tell you but I think
particular starting out as a good I did
draw okay just so we have an idea of
what we're doing two points okay I will
say P our variable point right X Y okay
Moo's so that it is equidistant
from D and s find the equation of it's
like okay now we've got already the the
important bits down I probably start off
with this layer here okay before I
launch into formulas I want to say what
the formulas are referring to right so
I'll say distance PD is equal to
distance PS okay so there's my
translation if you like from words into
an equation and now I can write my to
distance formula that's all these are
let's see here P 2d that's going to be
this the other way
okay now you have a go you simplify out
it looks at first like it's going to be
a terrible awful mess because when you
square it out there you have squared
stuff but you sort of already know what
you're expecting right because we got
out there and we actually stood in that
pattern so you know it should simplify
down go ahead and do it if you've got
something that's drastically different
you know something's going wrong
after that we'll draw